[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo Mirko heute fangen wir mal am Ende
an oder okay Toni dafür gehen wir in den
Sommer 2008 nach Münster
und was damals dort los war das weiß
BILD-Reporter Frank Schneider es gab
dann einen großen Prozess unter
unfassbaren Sicherheitsvorkehrungen beim
Landgericht Münster und man muss sagen
trotz der immensen Sicherheitsvorkehrung
ist dann trotzdem zu Auseinandersetzung
gekommen und zwar bei der Einfahrt in
die Stadt gibt's ein Park and Ride
Parkplatz und dort hatten dann eben ein
paar Bandidos gewartet und dann kam
jetzt endlich dazu und dann gab es eine
wilder Auseinandersetzung zum Glück war
die Polizei mit einem ihren Großaufgebot
vor Ort der bis zu 1000 Rockern
gerechnet am Ende war es noch die Hälfte
aber sie konnten dann auch sofort
eingreifen und den ersten Prozess da kam
knapp 100 Rocker dann sozusagen ja
Gewahrsamszelle verbracht zeigt aber
auch damals nicht unglaubliche brisant
das war auch absur muss man sagen dann
kam die Abordnung jeweils der Vereinten
Gruppierung und ging in den
Zuschauerraum getrennt durch sek
Polizisten dann saßen 15 Bandidos 15
Hells Angels mit dem Zuschauerraum also
es hatte auch wirklich absurde Rand
Erscheinung muss man sagen und dass der
Staat sich das damals halt so ein
bisschen gefallen lassen also könnte ich
mir heute so gar nicht mehr vorstellen
am Ende unseres heutigen falls steht
also ein spektakulärer Prozess in
Nordrhein-Westfalen bei dem sich
hunderte feindselige Rocker
gegenüberstehen am Anfang dieser
Geschichte aber wird ein Mann getötet
hier die Nachrichten vom 23 mai 2007
ein Mitglied der Rockergruppe Hells
Angels ist am Mittwochmorgen im
münsterländischen Ibbenbüren erschossen
worden die Rockergruppe ist seit Jahren
in einer teils blutige Fehde mit der
rivalisierenden Gang Bandidos verwickelt
ob die Schüsse auf den 47-Jährigen in
Ibbenbüren ein Ergebnis des bankenkriegs
sind wollte der Sprecher der
Staatsanwaltschaften Münster
Oberstaatsanwalt Wolfgang schwer
zunächst nicht bestätigen er sagte
lediglich wie ermitteln auch in diese
Richtung auf den Mitinhaber eines Harley
Davidson Ladens war morgen in seinem
Büro geschossen worden schwer ist
verletzt schleppte er sich noch in die
Werkstatt wo er zusammenbrachen der von
Mitarbeitern informierte Notarzt konnte
nicht mehr helfen
an diesem Mittwochmorgen schließt Rocker
Robert K von den Hells Angels gerade
seinen Laden auf weniger Augenblicke
später gibt es im Krieg zwischen den
Angels und den Bandidos ein neues
tödliches Kapitel Frank Schneider Herr
damals schwielten schon die
Auseinandersetzung gerade immer
insbesondere zwischen Bandidos und Hells
Angels damals gab es eigentlich nur die
beiden Rockerclubs in Deutschland aber
das eskalierte immer weiter und es gab
halt Auseinandersetzung es gab Überfälle
aber dann so eine kaltblütige
Hinrichtung eines Rockers wie dann 2007
in Ibbenbüren auch noch so im ländlichen
Bereich ein herzinsel der damals ein
Motorradgeschäft führte relativ normal
dort lebte mit seiner Familie also alle
die noch Kanten aus dem privaten Umfeld
gar nichts mit Rockern zu tun hatten als
sehr lieben Familienvater beschrieben
und der wurde dann in seinem Laden
getötet das war z.B auch so ein
Übergriff was man unter Rocker
eigentlich in deren Verständnis nicht
tat also dann tötet nicht bei sich zu
Hause man töte nicht von den Augen
sozusagen der Familie das macht man eben
nicht und das war so ein Übergriff im
doppelten Sinne also und sollte heißen
wenn jemand getötet werden schlimm genug
aber das war noch so eine Art er
Verletzung noch eine Grenzüberschreitung
im doppelten Sinne und das führte damals
auch dazu dass die Polizei halt sehr
alarmiert war und man hat dann auch
genau eben feststellen können dass zwei
Bandidos die Täter waren die dann
wirklich das aus weil dort dahin
gefahren sind an die Tat sich ausgeführt
haben wir eine wartet im Auto mit
laufendem Motor der andere geht rein
schießt 5 mal das war wirklich eiskalt
durchgezogen und hintergrund waren
vorausgegangen Auseinandersetzung im
Bereich nördliches Münsterland und
insbesondere auch Bremen zwischen den
verfallenden Rockerclubs und die waren
eben der Meinung weil er da auch eine
bedeutende Rolle spielt in dieser Robert
keine damals getötet wurde wir müssen
jetzt eine Exempel statuieren und wir
machen die das müssen jetzt einen Hells
Angel töten und das hat eigentlich ein
sehr langen Rockerkrieg nach sich
gezogen
[Musik]
das alles ist schon ein heftiger Fall
ich meine klar wer bei den Rockern
Karriere machen will der darf da kein
langweiliges Leben erwarten aber was da
im Mai 2007 abgeht das ist schon
bemerkenswert die Täter überfallen ja
Opfer in seinem direkten Lebensumfeld
sie schießen ihm gezielt in den Rücken
und sie töten dabei nicht nur einen
Rocker der sozusagen gegnerischen
Mannschaft sondern auch den Vater von
zwei Kindern im Alter von sechs und
sieben Jahren als die Polizei am Tatort
eintrifft sagt die Frau von Robert ka
den Beamten geradewegs den Mörder findet
ihr bei den Bandidos
falls wir unsere Podcast Episode Mord im
weltbüro noch nicht kennt ist das jetzt
in guter Zeitpunkt für den Hinweis da
mal reinzuhören dennoch da geht es um
den immerwährenden Krieg zwischen diesen
beiden Gruppen greifen wir mal kurz auf
diese Folge zurück
gegründet wurden die Hells Angels 1948
in den USA der Name stammt von einer
us-kampfliegerstaffel die im Zweiten
Weltkrieg Deutschland bombardierte ihnen
ist der bürgerliche Alltag zu langweilig
sie wollen Partys feiern und Harley
Davidson fahren ihr erster Boss ist ein
Maschinenführer namens Ralf Sony bracia
mit den Jahren kommt zum Motorradfahren
und den Partys das organisierte
Verbrechen dazu die Hells Angels
verdienen ihr Geld mit Erpressung
Zuhälterei und Drogen dazu kommen
Schießereien Waffen besetzt und
Vergewaltigung noch brisanter wird diese
Bedrohungslage durch rockerkriege denn
1966 gründet sich in Texas eine tödliche
Konkurrenz
die Bandidos das erste deutsche Hells
Angels Charter wird 1973 in Hamburg
gegründet weitere Ableger folgen
allerdings bilden sich in Deutschland
viele regionale Clubs die weniger gut
vernetzt sind und keine internationalen
Kontakte haben wie die Hells Angels in
den USA oder deren große Rivalen die
Bandidos nachdem es in den 1990ern ins
Skandinavien zu brutalen
Auseinandersetzungen mit mehreren Toten
kommt der eskaliert ab Mitte der 2000er
der Rocker kriegt zwischen Hells Angels
und Bandidos auch in Deutschland es
kommt zu Schlägereien Anschlägen und
Morden sucht den Mörder bei den Bandidos
sagt also die Frau des erschossenen
Robert K und die Polizei beginnt sehr
umfangreicher Ermittlungen sie braucht
nicht lange vier Wochen nach der Tat
nehmen Beamte den 48-Jährigen Heiner B
Fest der hat mal die Bandidos in Bremen
angeführt und er war selbst schon
zweimal Opfer einer Attacke der Hells
Angels zuletzt war er im
niedersächsischen Sturm mit
Baseballschlägern halb totgeschlagen
worden ein wichtiges Detail wie damals
auch Bild Polizeireporter Frank
Schneider bemerkt es geht am Ende immer
natürlich auch ums Geld und wer hat die
Vormacht wo und wer kontrolliert welches
bundesviertel wer kontrolliert wo den
Drogenhandel das führte
Auseinandersetzung aber am Ende wenn es
um diese Tötung gegen was eigentlich
immer so dass man hinterher gemerkt hat
auch vor Gericht bei den Aussagen wenn
überhaupt gesprochen wurde es ging auch
immer um diese es Erding also die Rocker
Ehre und das können uns nicht gefallen
lassen weil hier war so dass sie Hells
Angels ein oder andere
Auseinandersetzungen Vorfeld gewonnen
hatten nenne ich mal platt die Bandidos
auch nicht Prügel bezogen hatten und
jetzt wollte man sich eben sozusagen
rächen und hat sich dann einen
rausgesucht und hat den wirklich dann
heim türkisch getötet um die andere
rockergruppierung zu treffen Hintergrund
war das Robert Kah an der führenden
Persönlichkeiten in diesem Bereich war
aber letztendlich und so wollte man sie
eben besonders treffen
Werbung heute stelle ich euch einen
neuen Roman vor Sekunden der Gnade von
Dennis Lehane der New York Times
Bestsellerautor nimmt uns mit ins Boston
der 70er Jahre es herrscht aufgeheizte
Stimmung die Stadt kocht denn künftig
sollen schwarze Kinder mit Bussen in
weiße Schulen gebracht werden und
umgekehrt Angst und Hass machen die
Runde eines Nachts kehrt Mary Pet
fennessee 17-jährige Tochter joules
nicht nach Hause zurück Mary Pets
beginnt Fragen zu stellen aber sie stößt
auf schweigen und Widersprüche bis sie
begreift man hat ihr das letzte genommen
was ihr in dieser Welt halt gehabt außer
sich vor Schmerz macht sie sich auf um
Rache zu nehmen an den Verantwortlichen
und ihre eigene Schuld zu Süden und das
um jeden Preis große Erzählkunst Messer
Schafe Psychologie Bewegen des Drama und
spannend wie ein Thriller Sekunden der
Gnade von Dennis lahan ist jetzt
erschienen im Diogenes Verlag
Werbung Ende
im November nach dem Mord an Robert car
schnapp die Kripo einen weiteren
Verdächtigen und zwar den 36 Jahre alten
Thomas Kah Spitzname Addi der wohnt in
Westerkappeln also knapp 20 Autominuten
nordöstlich vom Tatort ibbenbüren
beide Festnahmen sind keine
Geniestreiche oder glückliche Zufälle
nee die sind das Ergebnis ganz
sorgfältiger Polizeiarbeit so wurden die
Handys beider Bandidos rund um den
Tatzeitraum in der Nähe geortet das
ergeben die Daten der Netzbetreiber
außerdem haben Zeugen im fraglichen
Zeitraum einen schwarzen van in der Nähe
von Robert Kaas Motorradladen gesehen
der Wagen lässt sich der Frau von Heiner
B zuordnen und nach der Festnahme werden
in der Wohnung von B auch noch Patronen
gefunden die exakt denen am Tatort
entsprechend das sind sehr gute
Ermittlungsergebnisse aber natürlich
sind das hauptsächlich weniger Beweise
für die Tat als mehr Indizien und so
überlegen sich die beiden mutmaßlichen
Täter und ihre Anwälte das Schweigen die
beste Strategie für den Prozess sein
könnte
fünf Monate sagen Heiner und Adi gar
nichts denn das immerhin ein Bandidos
und Hells Angels mit der Polizei und der
Justiz spricht man nicht
einziger aber gewichtiger
Schönheitsfehler dieser Taktik die
Staatsanwaltschaft hat einen Kronzeugen
einen 53-jährigen expandido der mal
Schatzmeister des Münsteraner
Ortsvereins der Bandidos war der Mann
hat viel zu erzählen
zum Beispiel wieder Mord an Robert K von
langer Hand geplant wurde dass der
Präsident des charters münster den Mord
höchstpersönlich angeordnet hatte und
das ist für einen Mord wie diesen das
begehrte Abzeichen expect no mercy gab
zu deutsch erwartet keine Gnade der
Gerichtsreporter des SPIEGEL beschreibt
diesen Kronzeugen damals so
Rolf D bewegt sich langsam und behäbig
schweren Schrittes tappt der Komponente
53-Jährige in den Schwurgerichtssaal des
Landgerichts Münster er trägt ein blaues
Sweatshirt eine ausgebeute Jeans schwere
Stiefel der Bart ist grau und ungepflegt
der Haarkranz zottelig der Blick trübe
die sieht aus wie eine Mischung aus
Weihnachtsmann und Tippel Bruder mit
einer starken Tendenz zuletzten er
schläft nicht mehr vielen jüngster Zeit
Zitat Ende dieser Kronzeuge berichtet
dass die Bandidos ursprünglich am
liebsten den kompletten Club der Hells
Angels platt machen wollten man habe
sich aber dann für eine kleinere Lösung
entschieden
das Bandido Rolf die der all das
ausplaudert der spielt mit seinem Leben
und er weiß das auch vor Gericht sagt er
wörtlich wenn die könnten würden sie
mich hier und jetzt vier Teilen
streng genommen kann auch Kronzeuge Rolf
D nicht beweisen dass konkret Heiner B
und Thomas kardi Todesschützen waren
aber die Kette von Indizien
Einschätzungen und Zeitangaben die ist
jetzt so fest dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft gute Chancen hat sie
fordert lebenslange Haft für die beiden
Bandidos die Verteidiger plädieren auf
Freispruch und so stehen alle für den
Tag der Urteilsverkündung bereit
Angeklagte der Richter Verteidigung und
Staatsanwaltschaft interessierte Bürger
die Presse und natürlich die entsandten
der beiden Clubs Hells Angels und
Bandidos aber genau einen Tag vor der
Urteilsverkündung gibt es plötzlich noch
mal Hektik bei Razzien in Bremen und
Niedersachsen werden 14 Hells Angels
verhaftet die an dem Überfall auf
Bandido Heiner B also auf den
Angeklagten beteiligt gewesen sein
sollen diesmal war es ein Aussteiger der
Gegenseite also der Hells Angels der der
Polizei Hinweise gegeben hatte der Mann
heißt Thomas p
Spitzname Tom er ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
32 Jahre alt trägt einen langen
schwarzen Zopf und gibt sich betont
lässig als er wenige Tage später vor
Gericht aussagen soll alle sind gespannt
ob er mit Details über den Rockerkrieg
nochmal alles ändert ob er zugunsten von
Anklage oder Verteidigung noch
entscheidendes beisteuert aber Hells
Angel Tom sagt genau genommen nichts von
Substanz und so kommt die erwartete
Entscheidung Heiner B und Thomas K
werden zu lebenslanger Haft verurteilt
es war ein zeigerschuss in den Rücken
sagt Richter Michaels gabran Frank
Schneider erinnert sich wir sind wegen
Mordes verurteilt worden es gab
lebenslange Haft und es ist auch einfach
so gewesen dass es wirklich sehr sehr
eiskalt vorbereitet war das muss man
wirklich sagen sehr durchdacht der
eiskalt es hat dann wie gesagt danach
lange lange Zeit immer wieder
Auseinandersetzungen gegeben auch in dem
Bereich und wir wissen ja heute auch
dass auch der Friedensschluss den es
damals dann gab
medienträchtig inszeniert zwischen
damals hanebuth den großen Hells
angelchef und dem europapresident der
vandilos am Ende ja auch nicht so
wirklich im Frieden geführt hat die
Mörder sind in Haft die Rockerbanden
verkünden ein Schweigen der Waffen und
doch knallt es bald schon wieder im
Krieg zwischen Angels und Bandidos wo
und wie das erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil
dieser Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland
wir freuen uns sehr wenn auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid euer
Mirko und eure Toni